welcome back to pj chain design today we
are going to talk about this
plate specific underneath the stone and
how does that going to make your stone
look
much brighter for jewelry cat design
with a rhino
6 tutorial are you ready let's get
started
[Music]
we're going to starting with the stone
size for 5 millimeter brownstone
and if you don't know how to make this
stone i have a video here i put the link
on the right top corner to show you
but if you would like to just download
it
you can download this file for the
practice the link
is at the description below okay let's
go to the top view
and we want to use a circle and the
circle
is about this size
holding the shift something a little bit
inside of the stone
now i want this circle to make a copy
and roughly
a little bit bigger something like that
and we can kind of a temporary hiding
the stone so we can see what is behind
it what i like to do is make some
triangle that so that will have a good
reflection so first we need to know
where the triangle is going to be
i'm going to use the command it's called
divide
you can divide as many as you want it
but i would like to divide it into the
18 section
so you can see the dot here is represent
the section here
i also like to divide this one
as well and then i want to divide it
into
18 section as well okay so with all the
section that i have with the dot
over here let me enlarge this one
and now i want to select all the point
that i have here
and we kind of wanted to rotate it
somewhere in between
so let me rotate it if it's 300 divided
by
18 is 20 i want to rotate it halfway so
i'm going to type it 10 degree here
so there would be something like this so
that's helping me
to making the line i'm going to make
sure my all snap is on
and the point it is on and i'm going to
draw a line from here to here
here to here to making this uh triangle
then next let's explode it so it becomes
a single line there
next things i wanted to do is draw
another line right
in the middle like this and this one
again
draw a line right in the middle it's
hard to know where
is actually the middle so you can split
this
curve by those point and this point
and then that will become just one
section so we want to draw a line
snapping into
here and snapping into the midpoint so
that will be exactly there
we need to have this line a little bit
taller so i'm gonna coming over
um my perspective let's go ahead and
pick up this curve
and this curve and turn on the control
point and we want to pick up this
point and the this point holding the
shift
and you can move it up for whatever how
high you want it so i'm just going to
move it at 0.4 millimeter
and i will get something like that if it
is too tall we can adjust it later
and then we simply just want to
connecting the dot from here to here
here to here and also from
here to here here to here
we also want to make a straight line
here
you can use the h for the round one if
you want to but since i like it
to be really fast looking so i'm going
to just draw a straight line
and let's go ahead to explore this one
and rest of it
is making bunch of the surface with the
command surface from two three four
edges
the same way you're going to pick up the
surface edge here
the curve and the curve and then you go
you get this one
all right so now we have this one all we
need to do
is join them together so that will be
one section
there and after that what we like to do
is
to make them complete the section so we
are going to use the
polar array and snapping into the zero
i would like to have 18 section of them
for 360 degree and that's how we get the
shape here
if you really like it just go ahead to
select everybody and join them
the second things i need to making a
thickness this is
has no thickness especially where it's
contact to the point
so we are going to use the command
duplicate
folder and that's going to give us the
boulder over there so let's go ahead to
pick up
this curve here and also the curve
with the shift on and then we click on
both of the curve and we want to go
into extruded curve straight and you can
straight uh extrude
whatever how tall you want by typing or
just moving your mouse down
and we'll have something like that and
don't forget to
don't forget to join them together so
now we have the whole piece there
and all we need to do is make them solid
by using the command
cap double check on our property it
shows
closed solid polished surface that's
turning back to
our stone here and take a look if you
like it
and if everything looks nice to you we
are going to go ahead to make
a prong set here i'm going to draw
a straight line usually we wanted to
have this lines a little bit taller
than our table and i'm going to have it
slightly taper it down
and make sure you cover the cool look at
at the bottom if you like to know more
about the stone setting you're welcome
to check out my course on my website
for all different kind of a stone
setting and in this case
we want to piping this guy to be
something about
this we like to cutting into the stone
it's about twenty percent of the
thickness on my prong
and so we kind of moving in for a better
position
now we have it we are going to uh using
the polar array
snapping into the zero and i would like
to have four of them
and uh 360 degrees so we can get this
one over here
now on the bottom to connect them you
can use
two rail or you can use a one solid one
i simply want to
creating two rail so i'm going to
snapping into the zero
and making something about this size
and moving this one down just a little
bit so this is going to
be the circle the rail i like to use the
conic corner so i'm going to draw a
square
and roughly like this coming over here
moving up my square
and i can tilt it if i want to we're
going to use a sweep one rail
and this is the rail this is the cross
section that will create the bar
underneath the facet part for it to sit
on
you can simply copy the cross section
moving down to the bottom
and then we are going to use a sweep one
rail one more time
and this is the rail this is the cross
section
and then we'll have another one over
here after that i would like to rotate
it
everything for 45 degrees there so the
prong will be
in this position then you can put the
bell and the jump ring
and that will be our pendant today i
hope you enjoy the video i have lot more
trick and tips
on my membership program if you're
interesting please check out my
membership program thank you for
watching
see you next
[Music]
you